can put me into a [ __ ] rage as my
fiance yeah other than that
it's really hard yeah you know what i
mean because she knows me personally and
when she does things to make me angry it
has to be on purpose at this point
because you know who i am
you [ __ ] evil woman you know yeah
yeah so what you're saying to me is if
let's say a guy just walks up to your
fiance and spits on her face
that's different that's personal though
oh okay that's really perfect my god if
somebody spit on your [ __ ] face
same reaction what my love for my fiance
is the same as my love for you
no if someone spit in her face right i'd
spit on his face
that's it i gotta walk away
yeah it's it's i forgot what
i bet you i got it what yeah yeah yeah
oh it's like the russian thing if you
hit me with a feather i'm going to hit
you with a tank
yeah be russian about it
yeah i don't i don't know i think if
somebody puts their hands on anybody i
mean whether i'm most likely i'm going
to get my ass beat but i have to at
least pretend like i'm going to do
something
yeah so you know okay if somebody came
up to your room i would be really angry
if he didn't give me the chance
to get to work like if someone
disrespected me and he
cut me off and wouldn't let me get to
that person
oh i would be really angry like if he
went got to him first i'd be like no
like let me
he disrespected me let me put my hand
let me feel the victory
of [ __ ] you know you're competitive
you're [ __ ] nuts dude
you're a little crazy well let me say
this actually i'm lying a little bit
because
the the girlfriend that i had before my
fiance there's like this like this weird
balance right that happens between
boyfriend and then a really comedic
moment
so like when we were at the we were at
the airport
and i remember this huge [ __ ] dude
started hitting on her while i
went to the bathroom and when i came
back i could see that she was very
uncomfortable
because this dude was like macking on
her right yeah he wasn't gonna do
anything but he was being a little
aggressive so i see it
and in my mind i'm like i should
probably step in and take her away
because she feels uncomfortable ah which
is the boyfriend thing to do
but the other part of me is like this is
[ __ ] hilarious yeah i went behind a
pillar instead
and i just kind of peek my head out to
see what was going on yeah and then i
texted her like yo what's going on
this man is making me feel really
uncomfortable because it helped me
cool well i'ma send a picture of myself
and tell him that this is your boyfriend
i just sent her a naked picture of terry
crews
[Laughter]
and she didn't talk to me for a solid
week i was pissed
if she was actually in danger i probably
would have stepped in but you know maybe
in your case too i expect her to be able
to handle her that's me like i really
want
someone to believe that i can
take care of myself so if you have
sweaty palms too just [ __ ] flick that
[ __ ] in their face
i have no problems i mean he's seen it
and he's like
if he's picked me up from let's say i go
to like a dive bar with my sister and
like he's like oh i'll come pick you up
i'm coming out of the comedy store and
it's on my way
no and then he'll see me waiting there
and then dudes are like harassing me
he won't come to my defense because he
knows me better no but that's also one
moment where i was picking you up from a
[ __ ] club
yeah right and you open up the passenger
door right
and you're some guy's macking on you
right there right and
you go this is my boyfriend right and i
love going
hi
you have to show him to show this man
right
you know some guy with a furry chest
he's yolked you don't mean he's got the
italian shirt on
you know i mean he's greasy you know i
mean and he thinks he's hot right
and i just love like just [ __ ]
spearing him in the heart
go i'm a [ __ ] little nerd and i'm
okay i'm taking her home
yeah with a piece of [ __ ] rolling in the
back
[ __ ] disgusting i've never been able
to get over that podcast well no i just
did it again
why two weeks ago why do you keep
[ __ ] in your car oh my god the last
time was when
a week before you were here too it's
like a sign that there's a sign
that you're coming yeah yeah
interesting yeah so you picked it up and
it looked like my face
it's like oh no but there's just
something there's a there's a connection
between you
and just [ __ ] in my car stuff in
your car